cette épreuve de dissertation elle fait
vraiment peur déjà elle dure cinq heures
et puis il n'y a pas vraiment de
programme ça calme n'est ce pas bon du
coup vous avez vraiment intérêt à
connaître les règles du jeu de cette
épreuve
moi je les connais bien parce que j'ai
préparer les concours de la fonction
publique pendant deux ans mais surtout
parce que chaque année je prépare des
candidats la dissertation de culture
générale du concours de le nm l'école
nationale de la magistrature si jamais
vous connaissez pas cette école j'ai
même commenté entièrement une copie qui
a été notée 15 sur 20 à ce concours vous
trouverez facilement la vidéo sur cette
chaîne youtube
dans cette vidéo je vais vous dire tout
ce que vous devez savoir pour préparer
l'épreuve de dissertation de culture
générale du concours de le m les
modalités à jour de l'épreuve jeudi à
jour parce qu'il y a eu des réformes
les caractéristiques des sujets qui
peuvent tomber et enfin la notation et
les résultats aux concours
alors c'est important de connaître tout
ça mais vous savez ce qui est plus
important
la méthodologie de la dissertation ça
tombe bien j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
profiter de mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation
vous pouvez vous y inscrire en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant en
haut à droite de la vidéo soit en
cliquant sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo
les élèves qui préparent le concours de
le nm l'adorent donc je sais que vous ne
serez pas déçu mais bon vous ne regardez
pas cette vidéo pour je vous parle de
méthodes rentrons donc dans le vif du
sujet que devez-vous savoir sur
l'épreuve de dissertation de culture
générale du concours de le n
[Musique]
pour commencer il faut préciser une
chose il ne s'agit plus exactement de
culture générale car l'épreuve s'appelle
désormais connaissance et compréhension
du monde contemporain où ccm s'est en
effet l'épreuve a été modifiée en 2009
dans le but d'améliorer l'égalité des
chances il s'agit désormais d'une
composition portant sur une question
posée aujourd'hui à la société française
dans ses dimensions judiciaire juridique
social politique historique économique
philosophique et culturel ou là en a le
choix
l'enjeu de l'épreuve est donc assez
clair c'est de montrer que vous
comprenez le monde contemporain à
travers une question posée à la société
française l'idée derrière c'est que vous
devez connaître le contexte
d'intervention du magistrat quant à
l'énumération de toutes les dimensions
de la réflexion elle signifie que vous
devez mobiliser des connaissances
transversales et je peux t'aider
supports variés et faire des
comparaisons européennes internationales
donc vous êtes libre de mobiliser divers
types de connaissances vous pouvez bien
sûr citer les références de culture
générale incontournable pour les
concours administratifs j'ai d'ailleurs
publié une vidéo dans laquelle je vous
donne une liste de 20 références
donc vous pouvez citer ce genre de
référence mais vous pouvez aussi citer
des décisions de justice des rapports
vous pouvez parler d'économie de l'avis
de l'administration vous pouvez parler
de plein de choses mais à deux
conditions
la première c'est que vous réussissiez à
inscrire votre réflexion dans une
histoire longue
les sujets sont certes plus orienté vers
les questions contemporaines depuis 2009
mais l'épreuve reste un exercice de
culture générale dans la mesure où on
attend de vous une grande ampleur 2 wii
et la question et contemporaine mais
votre analyse elle ne doit surtout pas
se limiter à l'actualité ou à l'histoire
récente
d'ailleurs les rapports de jury reproche
le candidat de trop se raccrochait
rallye l'actualité immédiate de la vie
politique française
la seconde condition à laquelle vous
pouvez mobiliser des connaissances
transversales
c'est de l'immobiliser au service de la
réflexion ça c'est une autre dimension
des réformes les plus récentes du
concours de le m
celle de 2009 et de 2010 en plus
d'améliorer l'égalité des chances et
réforme veulent décourager le bachotage
et repositionner les preuves sur la
vérification des capacités de
raisonnement
regardez ce que dit le rapport du jury
de 2019 la reprise de plans et fiches
préétabli est particulièrement négative
et ne peut abuser des correcteurs de
multiples copies
ça confirme ce que je répète dans toutes
mes vidéos la dissertation n'est pas un
contrôle de connaissances mais une
épreuve de réflexion et d'expression
écrite voila voila je vous ai dit
l'essentiel à savoir à propos de
l'épreuve
ce que vous devez retenir c'est que le
sujet portera sur un débat actuel de la
société française que vous pouvez et
devez mobiliser une grande diversité de
connaissances mais que vous devez le
faire au service de la réflexion que
vous devez démontrer une profondeur
d'analysé aller en garde les sujets
[Musique]
bon là on va être pragmatique on va
lister les sujets est tombé depuis 2009
comme ça on pourra se rendre compte de
leurs caractéristiques sur le plan de la
formulation on voit qu'il ya trois types
de sujets d'abord les questions
ça représente 40 % des sujets le
deuxième type de sujet
ce sont les notions entre guillemette
jeudi entre guillemets parce que l'eau
par exemple ça n'est pas vraiment une
notion mais bon vous avez compris ce
deuxième type de sujet c'est juste un
mot comme fraternité tomber en 2020 ou
la démocratie tombés l'année dernière
depuis 2009 ça représente un sujet sur
quatre enfin le dernier type de sujet ce
sont les locutions c'est à dire des
groupes de mou depuis le 2009 ça
représente un tiers des sujets comme
vous l'imaginez un sujet de dissertation
posée sous la forme d'une question ça ne
se traite pas de la même manière qu'un
sujet qui consiste en un seul nom
communs comme l'eau par exemple ça c'est
une chose que japon aux élèves de ma
formation avancée à la méthodologie de
la dissertation
voilà pour la formulation
intéressons-nous maintenant ou thème des
sujets qui sont tombés on peut déjà
remarquer que comme le voulait la
réforme de 2009
le caractère contemporain de la question
est important ensuite les thèmes sont
assez divers depuis 2009
égalité des chances le rôle de l'état la
confiance les frontières l'eau
l'identité la violence si terra j'arrête
là parce que ça change chaque année
s'il ya peut-être un thème global qui
revient plusieurs fois c'est la cohésion
sociale le vivent ensemble en 2011 en
2014 en 2018 et en 2001 mais bon ça
change quand même chaque année donc
c'est difficile de prédire le sujet
autre remarque grosso modo deux tiers
des sujets sont plutôt précis par
exemple celui sur les frontières celui
sur l'eau ou encore celui sur le
terrorisme ça veut dire que vous aurez
besoin de connaissances précises ou bien
que vous devrez être assez habile pour
traiter un sujet précis mais sans avoir
de connaissances précises
il existe des techniques pour faire ça
je les enseignes et également dans ma
formation avancée à la méthodologie de
la dissertation
voilà on a analysé les sujets tombés
depuis la réforme de
9 vous devez vous souvenir deux trois
choses première chose le sujet sera soit
une question soit une seule notion ce
nom commun souhaite une locution et il
n'y a pas vraiment un type de
formulation qui est plus probable que
les deux autres deuxième chose à retenir
le thème échange chaque année et enfin
troisième chose
le sujet est souvent précis allez il est
temps de parler de la notation et des
résultats alors tout d'abord qui seront
vos correcteurs des juristes
principalement du public
voici par exemple la liste des membres
du jury de 2019
regardons maintenant les notes les
rapports de jury disent que les
résultats sont comparables d'une année
sur l'autre
ces dernières années les correcteurs se
tiennent à une grille de notation pour
être les plus objectif possible comme
dans beaucoup de concours une bonne
partie des copies sont notés entre 8 et
10 c'est le ventre mou
ce sont les candidats qui n'ont pas raté
l'épreuve mais qui n'ont pas bien
traiter le sujet concernant les moyennes
ces dernières années c'est entre huit et
demi et neuf et demi pour le premier
concours c'est à dire celui des
étudiants les admissibles ont en moyenne
12 ou un peu plus de 12 tandis que les
normes admissibles tourne autour de 8
c'est à dire que si vous voulez vous
fixé un objectif simple pour être
admissible alors viser au moins 12
concernant le deuxième concours celui
des agents publics et le troisième
concours celui destiné aux personnes qui
veulent se reconvertir passer du privé
au public concernant ces deux concours
les moyennes sont grosso modo entre un
et deux points inférieure à celle du
premier concours c'est à dire que ça
tourne autour de cet ennemi huit ennemis
les admissibles ou en moyenne 11 ou un
peu plus de 11 tandis que les non
admissibles ou en moyenne entre 6 et 8
ça veut dire que si vous voulez vous
fixé un objectif simple pour être
admissibles à ces concours alors viser
au moins 11
mais il est possible d'avoir de très
bonnes notes en 2016
la meilleure note étaient 17 en 2000
8 18 et en 2019 17
après ces notes sont forcément rares si
vous voulez regarder les statistiques
dans le détail elles sont à la fin des
rapports de jury mais je vous conseille
de ne pas perdre votre temps avec les
statistiques détaillées
ça ne sera pas rentable pauvres pour
finir je vous rappelle les coefficients
de l'épreuve depuis 2020 l'épreuve de
connaissance et compréhension du monde
contemporain à un coefficient de 4 sur
un total de 17 ce qui veut dire
quelconque pour 23 5% dans votre moyenne
d'admissibilité ça fait presque un quart
ça veut dire que si vous avez 12 plutôt
que 8 ou bien 16 plutôt que 12
vous gagnez un point dans votre moyenne
générale et qu'est ce qui fait la
différence entre 1,12 et 1,8 entre 1,16
et 1,12 ce n'est pas la culture générale
parce que vous n'allez pas devenir
jacques attali en un ou deux ans non
c'est la méthodologie qui fera la
différence
je vous conseille donc de vous inscrire
à mon cours gratuits de méthodologie de
la dissertation souhaite en cliquant sur
le lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut
à droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo allez c'est l'heure de
conclure
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que vous devez retenir
de cette vidéo
pour faire simple retenez trois choses
vous devez réfléchir à une question qui
se pose actuellement à la société
française ensuite les formulations et
les thèmes des sujets varient mais les
sujets sont souvent précis et enfin pour
être admissible viser plus de 12 si vous
passez le premier concours et plus de 11
si vous passez le deuxième ou le
troisième est encore une fois la clé
pour réussir cette épreuve c'est la
méthodologie
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous sera utile je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote qui
dort là bas et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale rappelez vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour réussir à la dissertation de
culture générale au concours d'entrée de
le nm
[Musique]
on
oh